parce que tout ce qui va se passer c'est
que dès l'instant où un gouvernement
mettra ça en place les gens vont s'en
aller et vous dites que votre programme
n'est appliquée nulle part moi ce que je
vois c'est que il est déjà peu ou prou
appliquée en france depuis un certain
temps j'ai des exposés le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires qu'on subit en
réalité on est déjà un peu dans le germe
de ce que vous voulez mettre en place
vous ne ferez que prolonger les courbes
moi je pense qu'au contraire il faut
revenir là dessus et tout ce qui va se
passer c'est que vous mettrez votre
règle qui pardon je la trouve disons
absurde pour rester poli elle n'est pas
praticable et ça c'est assez
significatif de votre personnage c'est
qu'en fait vous faites des propositions
en l'air vous êtes ça pour le spectacle
vous faites un numéro vous n'êtes
absolument pas dans une démarche qui
consiste à devenir quand elle n'y
arrivait oui oui j'essaye de pardon je
déjeune chériaux mais je n'ai jamais
jeté insulte pas oui oui je suis là pour
animer vous fait un numéro et dévoué aux
fusées moi vous venez avec votre public
vous n'est que votre numérique qui ont
baissé quelqu'un aussi eric zemmour
aussi avec cette année fort valérie
blass excusez moi tout à l'heure mais là
on joue non mais vous savez comment vous
allez parler comme à cuba comme arriver
là et non non non mais des caricatures
et vous avez déjà monsieur mes amis je
devrais aller me laisser finir et ses
alliés un minimum poli dans ce débat
fini par être en direct déjà il ya déjà
aujourd'hui je parle de ma génération
j'ai 32 ans il ya déjà énormément de
français qui sans vous figurez vous mais
oui et deux jeunes français et pourquoi
ils s'en vont mais nan men alors
pourquoi ils s'en vont pour quoi ils
vont en angleterre aux etats unis ils
vont même à dubaï ils vont encore ils
vont nos des tas d'endroits comme ça
figurez vous que c'est parce que il
trouve que la france est devenue
poussines i je n'ai pas force d'être un
pays qui n'est pas dynamique
économiquement et qui n'est pas réformé
et moi je trouve qu'en réalité vous vous
foutez de la gueule des gens parce
qu'avec votre programme avec votre
programme
ne réforme pas le paie ce pays qui a
besoin d'être réformé en réalité les
premiers qui vont en pâtir ça va être
les premiers de cordée là ce qu'on
pourra plus s'occuper correctement de
l'hôpital parce qu'on pourra plus
s'occuper correctement mon jeu parce
qu'on pourra plus se tiendrait aussi ni
à force de paix est un pays réforme et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut un programme
sérieux et le candidat tueur sérieuse
donc oui moi je rejoins pécresse et j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est sérieuse et que
son programme est sérieux impressions et
qu'elle ne se moque pas des gens et
qu'elle est crédible parce qu'elle va
réformer la france pour non respect elle
viendra justement par les loups de mer
est dignement les gens et gardez votre
mépris bourg je vous ne vous lassez ou
polémique vous méprise parce que bah
c'est vous qui advient version géante
est toujours très mal dans vos propos et
tout le monde vient de le voir alors
parions de l'argument qu'il a donnée à
vendre là-dessus on va voir les
diarrhées verbales mais on a commencé
mais bien de bulgarie les gens en
arrivent là oui ça va vous être très
polis vous êtes da ros est vulgaire suis
désolé c'est pas dans la vie c'est ça
alors
j'arrive vers leurs attentes et les
chats oui oui jean ueberschlag
arguments on va émettre de côté le côté
tout à fait désagréable du personnage
regardons l'argument il savait bien sûr
il y en a deux il y en a 2 mais il aime
bien courir 10 et même des leaders
diktat wazemmes pas territoire et on lui
met pas la contradiction désolé par la
grippe selon luc mélenchon allez vous
qui par les talibans
on fera le dvd meme pas j'ai dit vous
aviez lu le programme si vous aimeriez
vous est présent j'avais envie de vous
écoute m'en aller j'aurais cochon alors
allons-y solidaire arguments il dit si
vous faites ça les gens sont ils oui ça
prouve qu'il n'a pas lu le programme car
kookaï en français
dorénavant je ferai comme elle serait d
amérique et nous partirons avant que les
américains des usa on pourra pas
échapper à l'exécution les usa pays
communiste bien connu et bien quand vous
êtes nord américain je vous garantis qui
court après eux dans le monde entier où
qu'ils soient ils ont vu leur a compris
la renarde impôts qu'ils doivent marange
25 pour tourner imposant je serai seul
un show on est déjà mis en cause a été
arrêté de parler un peu n'importe quoi
vous montrez vous taire je vais vous
montrer aux états il ya 25 ans
voilà comment ça se passe aux etats unis
d'amérique je ferai donc pareil
deuxièmement il dit les gens s'en vont
parce qu'ils trouvent que ce pays leur
prend trop c'est faux les jeunes
français qui partent ils vous travail à
l'étranger ils y vont parce que c'est un
intérêt de leur carrière et ils ont
raison parce qu'ils font des belles
choses à l'étranger et qui font valoir
ce que la valeur de notre pays de notre
éducation car ils ont été éduqués en
france et qu'ils sont souvent parmi les
meilleurs à l'étranger et donc à
l'étranger ils paieront la part d'impôts
qu'ils doivent à la france en échange
c'est vrai je m'engage à ce que pour ce
qui concerne les frais de scolarité de
leurs enfants qui ne l'est pas toujours
pris en charge aujourd'hui ce soit le
pays qui est le prennent en charge
puisque les enfants en france ont ils
sont éduqués gratuitement ce n'est pas
le cas mais on ou quatre dans mon esprit
on s'arrangera pour que l'enseignement
soit gratuit en france donc je ne crains
pas que les gens s'en aillent et ne
paient pas leurs impôts parce que quel
que soit l'impôt qu'ils ont à payer ils
le paieront fussent ils vont en enfer et
ceux qui partent à l'étranger je ne leur
reproche pas je ne dis pas qu'ils sont
partis par égoïsme ou parce qu'il n'aime
plus la france je dis qu'ils sont partis
parce que ça fait partie de leur
carrière et j'en suis content parce
qu'un jour ils reviennent au pays la
plupart proviennent au pays parce que
les conditions et ce au meilleur pour un
tas de raisons y compris les conditions
d'amour pour le pays parce qu'on vient
tous de quelque part et qu'on a envie
d'y revenir